MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
I'm here today
with Louise Mirrer,
who is the President of the
New York Historical Society.
And we're here to
talk a little bit
about Silicon City, this
fantastic new exhibit
that they've got.
I was lucky enough to
be at the opening of it.
I have a whole bunch of
questions for Louise.
And hopefully you do too.
I thought I would start
with just a few words
to introduce Louise and
tell you all about her
if you don't already know.
Even before that, I should
just-- how many of you
have been to the New
York Historical Society
or are familiar with it?
So think of it as
an opportunity.
LOUISE MIRRER: Got
some work to do.
MALE SPEAKER: It's
an opportunity
for expanding membership roles.
So in my opinion, one of the
iconic cultural and historical
institutions of New York
City, on the Upper West Side,
conveniently one block from
my daughter's middle school.
But just a fantastic place to go
with a host of great exhibits.
And as an unsolicited plug,
Louise has brought in a team
and has herself been responsible
for a tremendous rebirth
of an institution that
I've known for 45 years.
But that looks such a
dramatically more revived,
alive, and interesting
one than the one
that I attended as
a very young child.
So for all those
reasons, I'm especially
excited to have you here today.
Now I'll try to shut up
and get out of your way.
So I guess opening, tell us a
little about the Silicon City
exhibition.
What is it?
What does that name mean to you?
What was the genesis?
LOUISE MIRRER: So first of all,
I'm going to thank all of you.
I'm going to thank
Google because Google
has been a great partner
in this exhibition.
And I though I was
saying to William
before that my notes tell
me to save this for the end,
I'm going to start out by saying
that thanks to the partnership
with Google, we already
have 7,500 New York City
public school students
from elementary school
through high school
signed up to learn coding.
And apart from going through
the exhibition, the chance
for these kids-- you may
know that elementary schools
in New York City public
schools tend not to.
I don't know if any of them
actually teach coding yet.
So thanks to Google, these
kids have an amazing, amazing
opportunity.
So thank you very much and
thank you for being here.
So Silicon City, the genesis
of the exhibition-- first
of all the name.
We've all heard
of Silicon Valley.
of Silicon Alley.
And so we decided that we
would play a little bit
with New York's own
history in the story
and call the exhibition
Silicon City because in fact
what the exhibition shows
is that New York has been
central to the history,
the entire history
of innovative technology,
beginning with what we call
the Victorian internet
when Samuel Morse invented
the telegraph thanks to research
that was done in New York.
So that was in 1839.
We really traced
this amazing history
and established that
for a very long time,
you wouldn't think of
innovative technology
without thinking of New York.
MALE SPEAKER: I never heard
the phrase Victorian internet
before refer to the telegraph,
but I like that a lot.
If it's OK, I may
use that again.
LOUISE MIRRER: Sure.
MALE SPEAKER: So I going to
bash my question, two questions,
a little bit.
What made you think--
what kind of brought this
to the Historical
Society and brought it
Society in your mind?
LOUISE MIRRER: Well that's a
great question because people
ask me all the time, how
do you get the idea to do
an exhibition, any exhibition.
And I'm going to say
that maybe some of you
have great ideas for exhibitions
because that's basically
the genesis.
This one came out of
two social occasions
that I was present at.
The first was a branch that
an acquaintance of mine had.
I was talking to
a random person,
had never met him before.
But he was actually from
Mountain View, California.
And he said to me,
you know, there's
a great museum of computer
history in Mountain View.
And I thought that sounds
really interesting.
I went to Stanford.
So I'm always looking for
excuses to return to The Farm.
And I went that summer to visit
the Computer History Museum.
And one thing that
struck me instantly
from the start through the
finish is how much of the story
told at the Computer History
Museum took place in New York.
And then it was probably
only a couple of months
later that I was at another
social occasion talking
to Walter Isaacson, whose book
hadn't yet been published,
"The Innovators."
And I just casually
mentioned to him,
making small talk, that I had
visited this amazing museum
in Mountain View.
And he said to me, well my
book's about to come out,
and I did a lot of my
research there at that museum.
And you want to tell
the New York story.
So that was enough of a
coincidence of inspiring ideas
for me to talk to my
colleagues and then start
talking to people
with expertise really
all over the country
on computer history.
And that was the genesis.
So as I said, if any of you
have another great idea,
we're always happy
to receive them.
MALE SPEAKER: So
one of the things
that struck me in the
exhibit was the kind
of unique historical status that
the IBM Pavilion at the 1964
World's Fair places in
the exhibit in the history
of computing in New York.
Of course I had known
that the 1964 World's
Fair as being kind of a
component of "Tomorrowland,"
a somewhat regrettable movie,
and in a more minor way
a throwaway joke
in "Men in Black."
But maybe you want to tell us
a little bit about that IBM
Pavilion and what was that
kind of the icon of change
yet to come.
And how did what was
there-- how did that predict
what was yet to come?
LOUISE MIRRER: Well
of course as I said,
computer history stretches
back much earlier than 1964.
But it was really in 1964
with the World's Fair--
and it wasn't just IBM,
it was also Bell Labs.
MALE SPEAKER: Right, of course.
LOUISE MIRRER: But IBM had
this fabulous pavilion.
I happen to know it
was the first-- I
happen to know first hand.
I'm a little bit ashamed to
say because it will give you
an idea of how old I am.
But 1964 was the
first time I was
allowed to take public
transportation on my own.
And I was very young.
I would not have
allowed my own children
to do that today, more recently.
But I went to the World's
Fair with a few of my friends
in 1964.
And there were
lines-- I don't know,
we thought they were a
mile long-- that's probably
a bit of an exaggeration--
outside this pavilion that
looked like an egg.
It had been designed
by Eero Saarinen, who's
one of the great designers
of the 20th century.
And when you finally got a
chance to go inside the egg,
you became part
of a people wall.
You were hoisted up.
And someone came out like
looking like a conductor
in a top hat and tailcoat.
And you learned
about the future.
And the future, it was filled
with computers and technology,
and things that people in 1964
might have heard about, known
something about, but
really didn't think
were likely to change
the way we did things.
And the purpose of the
pavilion was really
to persuade us that
everything-- our kitchens
would behave differently.
Our everyday life would
be permanently altered.
And of course Bell Labs
had its picture phone.
The big joke among
my set was oh,
suppose you're in the
shower when the phone rings.
That's going to be
really embarrassing.
Somebody is going
to look at you.
And interestingly, we all
thought it was a big joke.
And we thought it
was a big joke.
Unfortunately it was a
big joke at the time.
They were way, way
ahead of their time.
The picture phone
was a huge flop.
Although I would
say that in addition
to Belgian waffles,
which we were introduced
to also at the Belgian
Pavilion of the World's Fair,
probably the picture phone was
the most exciting innovation
we learned about.
But back to your
question, we decided
that though we were going to
go back to the 19th century
to tell the history of
computers in New York,
we would actually start
by inviting visitors
to enter Saarinen's egg and
be inside the World's Fair.
And we did that so
that people could
see what everyone thought the
future would bring, and then
go back in time.
Once you leave the egg,
you do go back in time
to the 19th century.
And you get a chance to
see why people thought
that future was possible in
'64, and what was possible,
and how long did it take
before we had picture
phones as a way of life.
MALE SPEAKER: I guess
this is a picture phone.
LOUISE MIRRER: That's
a picture phone.
MALE SPEAKER: In '64 you got
to see what did turn out to be,
I guess to many's surprise,
a vision of the future.
But what were some of the
biggest surprises to you
as the exhibit was being
curated and assembled,
anything you learned
about New York's role
that you hadn't known?
LOUISE MIRRER: Well
I must say that one
of the most interesting
things that I really learned
was as much about history
as it was about technology.
And that was that-- you
know, I'm a historian
and I run an American
history museum.
So I know that Article
I of the Constitution
requires a census
every 10 years.
And that was really critical
to figure out how to tax people
and how to apportion
representation in 1790 when
the first census was taken.
And I also was very aware that
at the end of the 19th century,
we had an enormous population
explosion in this country.
But I was not aware that
actually the punch card
system, which was something I'm
very familiar with, though I
wasn't around in the 1890,
but the punch card system was
actually developed by Herman
Hollerith in order to-- you
probably all know this,
but I did not-- in order
to accommodate the
need to take a census
in an era of huge, huge
massive population growth.
So I think that one of the
really interesting things
about the exhibition
is the opportunity
to understand scientific
discovery as a companion piece
to our historical trajectory.
What also really surprised me--
I also was one of the first
to take a transistor
radio to Jones Beach.
I grew up in New York
as I said before,
so Jones Beach was sort of like
where you went over the summer.
And it was very exciting
to have this little pocket
radio that you could play
your rock and roll music when
you were getting a
sunburn on the beach
since we didn't know any
better in those days.
But I didn't really
realize how the development
of the transistor really
revolutionized the ability
for all sorts of
things to happen.
And one of the discoveries
I made along the way-- one
thing that happens when
you work on an exhibition
is you meet incredibly
interesting people,
in my case, people you
wouldn't ever otherwise meet.
And I met a guy from
the Bronx originally
who used transistor technology.
He had gone to City
College and he actually
invented this while he was
a student at City College.
He used transistor technology
to develop an instrument called
the cardiotron.
And the cardiotron
allowed a doctor
to move around with a
cardiogram machine, which
was an enormous innovation
because you could figure out
what someone's
heartbeat was remotely.
And in fact he showed me some
pictures of his sales pitch.
And my own father
was a cardiologist.
And lo and behold I found my
father in one of the pictures--
so that was really
quite incredible-- who
was receiving a demonstration.
But so many things were
certainly new to me.
What wasn't new to
me, but is new to so
many of our young visitors
was a Selectric typewriter.
And I typed my dissertation
on a Selectric in 1980.
And that seemed like
a huge innovation.
I mean, little did I know
that five years later, you
know I would have tossed the
Selectric in favor of an IBM
word processing machine.
But at the time
it seemed amazing.
And what happens is we decided
to have a bank of Selectrics
for fun.
MALE SPEAKER: I loved
that by the way.
Oh, the feel of that typewriter
keyboard is just unparalleled.
LOUISE MIRRER: Well
what happens is
that the most amazing
thing in the world
to our very young
visitors is this bank
of Selectric typewriters.
And they are waiting in line
to have a chance to type
on this thing.
And as one of my
colleagues said,
he quoted his son
as saying, it's
amazing to have a computer
that you can type on
and it prints at the same time.
Wow.
[LAUGHTER]
Back to the future as they say.
MALE SPEAKER:
Where's the screen?
Something you touched
on a minute ago
when talking about
the interconnectedness
of technology and
science in the area is I
think there is this theme
of the interconnectedness
or the role of technology in
New York's great industries.
And of course New York is
great at many, many things.
But media, culture, we're
arguably the greatest
in the world.
And there certainly
seems to have
been a great kind of
technology component
to media, culture, finance,
these other New York
industries, institutions.
LOUISE MIRRER: Well I think
that's why New York was
so central to
technological innovation
because a lot of things
were happening here
that were on the cutting edge.
Culture is really
key among them.
So the earliest experimentation
with, for example, music, art,
dance, Cage and Cunningham
to give one salient example,
they were really learning
about innovations
in computer technology
and figuring out
how they could make
what, at the time,
sounded like totally weird
sounds and movements.
And we have a wonderful little
video in the exhibition.
You can see they're
hooking up a toaster
and I think maybe a
blender also to make music.
And it's very funny and
sort of Chaplinesque.
But experimentation has
always been the calling card
of culture in New York.
And we have a long
history of bringing--
we did an exhibition
on the 1913 Armory Show
in New York which introduced
New York to modern art.
Modern art came to New York.
It shocked a lot of people.
And this kind of
new music, computer
generated music,
computer generated sound,
I mean it's no accident that New
York is just a very open city.
And the early experimentation
really all happened here.
And some of the
other discoveries
that we made along the way
were that actually things
that are really
closely associated
with Hollywood or with
California more generally,
like Toy Story, pixilated
movies, computer generated
films, actually
also happened here.
And some of the academic
institutions in town
were really central
to all of that.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you think
that that-- so having
gone to school at Stanford and
been to the Computer Museum
and so on, is this core
to New York's technology
identity a difference from
the Silicon Valley one, which
is now very, very focused
on consumer experience
of technology directly?
LOUISE MIRRER: Yeah,
I think New York
was central for a long
time to innovation,
kind of mechanical innovation.
And then I think--
I was at Stanford
at a time when
Stanford was really
promoting its faculty to do
research, innovative research.
And I think probably
the understanding
of how you could commercialize
an invention that came out
of an academic
institution was more
West Coast than East Coast.
And I think that that probably
gave Mountain View and Silicon
Valley its edge.
But I think New York
has retained industries
that make a company like
Google an attractive partner
for the city.
We have advertising here.
So anyone who has a business
model that requires proximity
to advertising agencies, New
York's a good place to be.
Culture, the same thing,
certain kinds of culture,
maybe not Hollywood films
or games these days.
But I think that
New York has really
hued, even during the
time that we argue--
I mean, we basically
abandon the story
in the 1980s in our exhibition.
We go through the end of
the '70s and then we say,
it moved to the West Coast.
We have a little bit on the '90s
because certainly the capital
markets in New York
were paying attention
to technological
innovation in the 1990s.
And then we restart the
story in the present.
MALE SPEAKER: And the present
seems like an interesting time
and a bit of a difference.
Now they call it the tech
renaissance in New York,
but renaissance
implies-- I guess
rebirth implies there was
death along the way when
the point of the exhibit is in
fact that was never the case,
right?
But it does seem
like New York now
has a tremendous number of
small, medium, and large sized
companies that are--
technology is the business,
not just an enabler for the
business or a component of it,
much more mirroring what's been
done in Silicon Valley I guess.
Do you see that as
a permanent change?
Is this changing the landscape
of New York-- the economics,
the political dynamics?
LOUISE MIRRER: Oh absolutely.
I think Google is a very,
very big part of that story
because this building has
anchored a whole new rebirth--
certainly you've been part
of a whole new rebirth
of Manhattan's Far West Side.
And I think that the whole--
I live on the east side,
despite the fact that I
work on the Upper West Side.
But neither of
those places really
is sort of the center of what's
happening today, certainly
not in technology.
And I think that the personality
and the geography of the city
has been very, very much
changed by the renaissance
of technology here.
And I think also
that what's very nice
is that companies
like Google and others
that have sunk their
roots in New York
really understand
that you can still
attract a different
kind of person
to work in technology
at New York
perhaps, in New York
than on the West Coast.
I'm a New Yorker.
I'm fourth generation
New Yorker,
so I'm very New York focused.
But I do think that it's nice
to see that startup technology
companies that are doing
really great cutting edge
kinds of things,
companies like Google,
are recognizing that New
York really has a special DNA
and that it's fun to
work here in the city.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
Well I'm glad we
agree, absolutely.
So maybe talk a little
bit more about the coding
experience, the coding teaching
that's going on at the exhibit.
This seems like
kind of a new thing
for the Historical Society.
LOUISE MIRRER: Well it is.
We were really
glad for the chance
with this exhibition to talk
about science because there's
such a focus on
trying to prepare
new generations for
work, for having
the capacity to work in these
new industries these days.
And we have a lot
of kids who visit.
Some of you may know
this, but New York forever
has required, if you're
in a public school,
has required you to
pass an American history
Regents examination
in 11th grade.
If you don't pass it, you don't
graduate from high school.
And as everybody
knows, you don't
graduate from high school, you
tend to have zero life chances.
So we've been very much
about leveling the playing
field at the New York
Historical Society.
And we've spent a lot
of time and energy
trying to make sure
that students are--
of course we believe in it.
They should know
American history.
their local history.
But they should also be able
to graduate from high school.
So we've spent a lot of
time and energy doing that.
But we haven't really had a
chance to prepare students
for careers in
science and technology
because we focused on history.
And this exhibition really
gave us the opportunity
to say well what can we do now.
And as I said at
the start, we were
very fortunate to have a
partnership with Google,
because we got
expertise from you.
So your colleagues
have enabled us.
We have some great videos
which you can access on online
and have a great time watching.
It's fun for us.
I'm sure it would
be fun for you too,
to introduce very
young kids to coding.
And you know it is a skill that
is extremely very necessary.
And it is a skill that just--
I guess they don't really
have the bandwidth to do it in
the early grades in New York
City public schools.
So we have the opportunity
to any teacher,
any class throughout the city
and the public schools to come.
The students get a guided
tour of our exhibition.
And then they spend an hour in
one of our Google classrooms.
So we've got three Google
classrooms, one very big one
and two nice sized
ones, but not as big.
And they spend an
hour learning coding.
And it's really a lot of fun.
So it's great.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Very cool.
It's great we can do that.
Never would I have thought that
I would have the opportunity
as part of Google to collaborate
with the New York Historical
Society.
It's kind of one of the great
thrills of being part of Google
in New York for me I think.
I'm out of my question list.
And I wonder if it would
be OK for us to open up
to questions from the audience?
LOUISE MIRRER: Sure.
MALE SPEAKER: We have
mics on either side.
I see Ramona is bravely going--
LOUISE MIRRER: You ask
me anything technical
I'm going to throw
it back to you
to answer, so just as a warning.
AUDIENCE: Hi,
thanks for visiting.
You've spoken about West
Coast versus East Coast.
But I'm also be curious to know
if you have insight into why
some of the tech industry
moved out of New York
into the suburbs, and now it's
moved, which I think is great.
But do you have any
thoughts on that?
LOUISE MIRRER: Yeah.
We actually did a
couple of years ago now,
we did an exhibition called
World War II and New York.
And the exhibition
really showed how,
at the end of World
War II, manufacturing
which had been so central to
the city and the environs really
moved to the West Coast.
I mean already you
could see Grumman
and the aircraft industry
was out on Long Island.
But manufacturing writ large
was starting to leave the city.
It was already
migrating to California.
And I think that really,
part of the story
is that New York became less
hospitable for a whole range
of reasons after World War II.
There's more land, cheaper,
more energy, cheaper, geography,
real estate.
And there were new
industries that
came to New York and
supplanted manufacturing,
like all the culture.
The University in Exile, New
School University for example.
So I think it's very complex.
But I think this started
at the end of World War II.
New York fell on very
hard times in the 1970s.
It was really not a
great place to live,
not a great place to work.
People fled to the suburbs.
You would not be sending
your children to school
on the Upper West Side.
MALE SPEAKER: I grew up on the
Upper West Side in the 1970s,
so I have the scars to show it.
LOUISE MIRRER: No, I remember
coming back from college one
year and I stayed
with a friend who
lived in one of these now
glorious apartments in the West
80s.
And you could hear
the shots ringing out.
So I think that was part
of the complex of things
that happened.
And that's what
happened, changed.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
It's the skeletons of
those institutions that
remain I think are interesting.
So I worked for
Columbia University
in what had been IBM's
original Watson research labs,
115th Street, and Bell Labs
had originated downtown.
You can kind of
see the skeletons
of these institutions,
or they're still
present on the
streets of Manhattan.
We have another
question over there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
I had a question
about sort of-- again,
you mentioned this
earlier, but kind
of the reputation of New
York versus Silicon Valley
is kind of the
grassroots support
of the tech industry from its
citizens and constituents.
And New York, for
better or worse
has sort of avoided a
lot of the problems that
have affecting the Bay Area
with a reputation of creating
these little startups that
promote either the gig
economy as they say-- your
Ubers, that sort of thing.
And New York also
has a lot of startups
that make real tangible things.
And I was wondering in the
course of putting together
this exhibition if you
saw any sort of trends
in that way of sort of the
continuation of New York
as kind of an
engine of innovation
in its historical sense.
I know you just talked
on that a little bit,
but this idea that
people build things
in New York that are useful and
that are useful to everyone.
LOUISE MIRRER: Yeah, well
that's a great question.
And the first question
was a great question too,
which I couldn't do justice to.
But there are some great
books on suburbanization.
But I would say in the last
gallery of the exhibition,
we have a case that has some
3D printed objects in it.
We worked with Shapeways, which
is one of the newer 3D printing
companies.
And I love the idea
that 3D printing
seems to have really taken
hold as an industry in New York
because they are
making real things.
I think Wall Street suffers a
little bit from the same thing.
What's this capital?
There's no there there.
But I think that it
does sort of return
the whole phenomenon of 3D
printing and its uses from-- I
think it's great if
I have a dinner party
and run out of spoons that I
might have [INAUDIBLE] make
one-- on the trivial end to
the really serious robotics
applications of a 3D printing.
I think it's great that New
York has sort of returned
to its manufacturing
roots in that sense.
And I feel that it doesn't
really undermined anything
about the intellectual
purpose of New Yorkers
and what's done at
various universities.
But maybe that's a
way of seeing it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thanks for coming.
Forgive me, I haven't been
to the exhibition yet,
so this question
probably belies that.
And it's a little
bit of connection
to the first question as well.
And it's sort of
curatorial question.
When I think about this
sort of time period
of the birth of
computing, I think
of New Jersey and Princeton,
places very allied to New York.
But I was just
wondering what you
decide New York is when
you're talking about this.
Is it Rochester?
Is it Manhattan?
Is it Montauk?
I was just wondering
when you were deciding
that, how did you sort
of say what New York was,
what the Silicon City was, and
how far its tendrils kind of
extended?
LOUISE MIRRER: Right.
So Bell Labs actually
started right around here.
So we're almost home.
We're almost at ground
zero in terms of Bell Labs.
And ditto for any innovation
that was connected.
I mean Columbia's Watson Labs
for example on 116th Street.
I mean, IBM's
headquarters have always
been on 57th and Madison.
So New York City, many
people don't know this.
They think that
Bell Labs was always
in New Jersey and Murray Hill.
I mean, I say Murray Hill, and
people think I mean Manhattan,
but there is a Murray
Hill in New Jersey.
MALE SPEAKER: Actually here
when you say Murray Hill,
people think you
mean New Jersey.
LOUISE MIRRER: A lot of jokes
about Manhattan's Murray
Hill, so I won't go into it.
But actually if you
trace the history
when Samuel Morse was working
on the telegraph, he was here.
He was right here.
So Edison, Thomas Edison also.
I mean, all of the
early inventions
really relate to what we would
call strictly New York City.
But we're very broad minded.
And we do think that there
is sort of a tri-state area
that we can claim as New York.
So we do play a little bit.
IBM of course
moved up to Armonk,
and then it moved further north.
And we do go out to Princeton.
We certainly have gone
out on Long Island.
So yeah, so we do
fudge a little bit.
But you know,
Silicon Valley is now
a huge-- I mean,
where did it start?
It started in a
very small location.
I don't even know what the
geographical boundaries
are anymore.
So if they can do
it, we can do it.
AUDIENCE: We did it first.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
You were mentioning
earlier about teaching kids
to program in school.
And I remember when I was
in grade school in the '80s,
they taught us
BASIC programming.
And the first code I ever
saw was my math textbook.
But I guessed that stopped
happening at some point.
Did your research uncover why
that no longer was happening
in public schools,
and kind of if that's
going to start happening
again, to teach kids to code?
LOUISE MIRRER: Well,
you know, there
are a lot of things going
on in schools today.
So what tends to
happen is you have
a very prescriptive curriculum
that basically teaches you
what you need to know
with a view of passing
a benchmark exam.
It's no secret that
kids-- maybe the pendulum
is swinging in a different
direction these days.
But testing became
increasingly important.
So I think what happened
was that you tended
to develop a curriculum that
would be focused on what you
needed in your benchmark
exams really early on,
fourth and fifth grade.
I mean, there always
were, but there
was a lot more freedom
I think for a teacher
to help kids explore.
And that really
stopped happening.
No Child Left Behind
was big legislation.
I guess I'm trying to think.
It came in with the second
Bush administration,
so not that long ago.
But it really did alter the
picture for what kids learned.
So the curriculum became
tighter and tighter.
I think there was
a lot of pressure
on the New York City public
schools, probably not all that
long ago, maybe in
the last decade,
to prepare students for
careers in new technology.
And as a result they
started introducing
coding in the high
schools because the logic
was, you're at the tail end of
your career in public school.
And now is the time
to teach you skills
that you would
need to get a job.
But it's actually much too late.
You'll all know that.
You'll all recognize that.
It's much too late.
First of all, the
dropout rate, even
though it's improved
hugely-- I mean,
there's a huge dropout rate.
I don't know what the percent.
I used to know the percentages.
But it's pretty big.
So there are a lot
of kids that just
don't make it to high school.
So if you haven't
started them on a path,
they're never
going to get there.
And I think that--
we certainly think
that introducing coding
for public school
kids in elementary school is a
way of saying stay in school,
because you're already
on your way to a career.
And I think basically that's--
I could go on and on talking
about it because it's
sort of a hobby horse.
But we feel very, very
strongly that this
is one of the greatest
things that we can do
is to give a New York City
public school-- and most
of the kids who
come to us are free
lunch, free breakfast kids.
So they're really
getting an experience
that you would get
as a matter of course
in a private school That.
You would not get
in public school.
MALE SPEAKER: If you're also
interested in learning more
about what Google
is doing, there
are K-12 programs run out
of NGDU that are done here
in the New York office.
I'm sure it would be easy to
connect to the people working
on that stuff and give you more
of our perspective on what's
going on.
AUDIENCE: Great.
That' s a lot.
LOUISE MIRRER: And by the
way, when we do an exhibition,
we don't sort of go cold turkey
when the exhibition ends.
So every time we
do an exhibit, it
leaves an imprint on
whatever we do forever.
So we expect that this will
be a part of our offerings way
beyond the exhibition.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh that's great.
I did not know that.
That's awesome.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for coming.
I also didn't make it
to the exhibition yet,
but I heard your
comments earlier
about the lapse of
computer history
in New York in the 1990s
and how it came back.
I wanted to ask
about-- certainly
it's true when we think
about the internet.
I mean, all the internet
based computer history
was made out west and
came back to New York.
But computational
finance, for example,
has mostly been in
New York because
of the essential position of New
York in the financial markets,
and to a lesser degree
Chicago and London
I guess, but certainly
not out west I think.
So what kind of flavors
of computer history
are you representing
in the exhibition?
What kind of weights are
you giving to each one?
LOUISE MIRRER: Yeah, well
business was-- even though
Thomas Watson Sr. Came out of a
marketing and sales background,
he was at National
Cash Registers.
I guess that was NCR,
the original NCR.
And then IBM was International
Business Machines.
And we do focus
very, very heavily
in the exhibition on the kind of
companionship between business
and New York, a focus
on business in New York,
and the need for
business machines,
the need for computers
to support business.
What we basically
decided was look,
the 1980s is so much
more of a West Coast
story in terms of innovation
where really, we're
not going to-- I mean, there are
people who have argued with me,
and they're right, that
it's not like we fell off
the charts completely.
But we just decided that the
1980s was not the New York
story.
And we decided that we
would cover the 1990s
in a film, which actually Fred
Wilson persuaded me to do.
He said without the
venture capital,
even if it was venture capital
to support the computer
industry on the West Coast,
what was happening on the West
Coast, it was still
coming from New York.
And in the 1990s, companies
like JP Morgan, their largest
segment of investment was
going into the tech industry
in the 1990s.
So we didn't abandon
the 1990s completely.
I mean you're right.
You're right, we could
have gone straight through.
And business and
technological innovation
have always beem-- I mean,
we do make that point.
When you come to the
exhibition, you'll see,
we do make that point.
But then again, in
the present time,
there are so many
other directions
that technology has
gone in in New York
that, though business is
still extremely important,
technology has
developed in ways that
are completely independent of
what's going on on Wall Street.
And Wall Street isn't a
geographical location anymore
anyways.
MALE SPEAKER: Hasn't been
for a long, long time.
LOUISE MIRRER: I mean,
there's a name on the street,
but it's much more diffuse now.
MALE SPEAKER: So this
idea about there's
being so many
parts of technology
there are uniquely New York, one
of the sharpest CTOs I know who
has a whole bunch of interesting
problems in distributed
computing is the CTO
of Rent the Runway.
And it seems to me
like that seems to me
to be kind of New York
in such a great way.
LOUISE MIRRER: Yeah,
that is terrific.
MALE SPEAKER: It's
finance and it's fashion.
LOUISE MIRRER: Yeah, that's
great, great example.
AUDIENCE: So you've come back
a few times to the issues
surrounding the sort of flight
from the city and the Ford
to New York, drop dead era.
And it seems also that sort
of the tech renaissance
coincides with the
reemergence of the city
as a desirable place
and people moving back.
So I was curious with the
rise now of virtual reality
and telepresence and
self-driving cars,
how do you see those things
impacting things going forward?
Do you think it will somehow
help concentrate things?
Do you think it will
defuse things again,
or kind of won't matter
that much to the city?
LOUISE MIRRER: No, I mean
I think you're right.
New York is back.
And I think it really is back.
And I think all of
those innovations--
I think the idea that you could
have a driverless car in New
York is so appealing,
unbelievably appealing.
MALE SPEAKER: I think it
beats the drivered cars I've
seen in many cases in New York.
LOUISE MIRRER: Make
it happen, now.
I think New York has come back.
It's really not a coincidence.
We had leadership in the
city, certainly beginning
with the Giuliani
administration which
was very focused on making
New York a safe place again.
You know, no accident that he
had a career as a prosecutor.
And that's where he
decided to put his eggs.
And then we had three terms
of Michael Bloomberg, who
was very, very focused on
enhancing the city's reputation
and ability as a
center for technology,
including creating a whole new
campus that resides right here
in this building right now.
And I think it would
be a great pity, given
that that campus
will be opening,
I think in a couple of years--
MALE SPEAKER: Next year I think.
LOUISE MIRRER: In one year.
I was saying with William
before, I'm watching it.
I live actually across
the river from it.
So I'm watching it out of
my bedroom window as it
sprawls, frozen sprawls.
I think that we have
bet with that campus
and with your presence here
and with everything that's
happening, we've really
bet on the future
of New York as a center.
I think that will only thrive.
We don't know.
I think what the
1964 World's Fair
told us was that we
really have no idea what
the future's going to bring.
But I've always bet on
New York, and I would
continue to bet on New York.
AUDIENCE: So your comment
about Cornell Technion
is a perfect segue to what
I was going to ask about,
which is you've mentioned
Stanford a few times.
And you're an alumna.
And of course Stanford
was a big part
of why Silicon Valley happened
in Palo Alto, and Stanford
Research Park and HP and so on.
What do you think the role has
been of-- we have fantastic
universities here, Columbia,
NYU, and further afield,
well obviously CUNY in the
city, but further afield
Princeton and Yale and so on.
What has been the role there?
Could they have had
more of an impact
as Stanford did
on the West Coast?
And what do you think
looking forward,
especially with Cornell
Technion, what's
the role for them going forward?
LOUISE MIRRER: Well it's
another really great question.
I was the provost for the
CUNY system for seven years
before I took my job at the
New York Historical Society.
And the view at CUNY was that
great engineering had really
been coming out of
particular of City
College for a very long time.
City College had a lot of
collaborations with Columbia.
NYU had had an
engineering school,
but sort of closed it I
guess is the short form,
because it's true.
So there have been great
opportunities I think.
And I think Columbia and City
were pioneers in robotics
and did a lot of work.
Princeton obviously,
great examples.
But they haven't been Stanford,
and they haven't-- you know,
I think it just goes back to--
I was an academic still for most
of my career.
And I think that there has
been a sense among East Coast
academic institutions that
it's a little bit-- how can I
say this politely--
it's just not
right to have commercial
academic partnerships.
And I think Stanford's
great strength
was to sort of pioneer
encouraging that.
And so I think maybe
it's fair to say
that New York institutions
focus more on culture,
more on the humanities.
They withdrew a little
bit with the closing
of NYU's School of Engineering.
They withdrew from engineering.
They didn't see
the opportunities.
I mean, you look at
the corridor, Boston,
MIT for example, I
think it's probably
fair to say that New
York did lose ground.
Could we have had relied
on the institutions
already in the city to have had
a homegrown-- you know, Cornell
Technion institution maybe?
But there's always
excitement around something
new and different.
And PR means a lot.
It means a huge amount.
We spend a lot of
money on advertising
at New York Historical.
So I'm the first person
to say, to announce things
to the world, we're
doing-- we've changed
our business-- is very useful.
So I think the addition of a
new campus focused on technology
is a good thing.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
I wonder, do you
think it's possible that
some of those universities
had a bit of "The Innovator's
Dilemma" class of problem?
When I worked at
Columbia, they received
a lot of technology transfer
and IP revenue from stuff
coming out of medical school.
And as a result there
was an institutional bias
towards pharma and
the relationships one
has with pharma and
medical device companies.
And do you think it's possible
that there were situations
like that that positioned us
poorly as a city for this newer
computing industry?
LOUISE MIRRER: I think
that's a really good point.
And now thinking back,
yeah, that was really
the main event I would
say at City College
were medical devices.
So you're right about that.
I mean, I hate to say it, but
I think it's probably true
that we just really
weren't thinking,
notwithstanding the fact that
Bloomberg started here and was
a huge as a company, was a
huge innovator in all respects,
I mean really in every respect.
I think we just probably
missed the boat a little bit.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
maybe one last question
and then we should let
Louise get a drink of water
or something like that.
AUDIENCE: What did
you wish you could
have fit into this
exhibition that you
weren't able to include?
LOUISE MIRRER: Gee, a lot.
There are really a
lot of things that we
would have liked to talk about
but didn't have the space
to do.
We would have liked to have
done a whole arcade of games,
because that is a part
of New York's history.
We have one game
that you can play,
Space Invaders, which
was invented here.
And it's a lot of fun.
I think my colleagues
and I, we would
have loved to have had the
chance to recreate the energy
and excitement of
New York when that
was a big thing and a big focus
of social sort of collection
of people in the city.
We would have loved
to have done that.
We also would have loved to
have had much more around art
and culture.
We'd have loved to have had
a whole gallery showing some
of the great art that really
speaks to what computers
brought to contemporary art.
We'd love to have done
those kinds of things.
But you know, all
things being equal,
we would love to
have incorporated
one of our Google classrooms
into the exhibitions.
By the way tonight,
we're launching drop in,
we're using our classrooms.
Friday night were
pay as you wish,
which as a person
who counts the money,
I can tell you pay
as you wish means
you don't have to pay a lot.
But because we're usually
flooded with visitors Friday
night as a result
of our openness,
we want to make the
museum open to anyone
whether they can pay
admission or not basically.
But we are allowing people to
drop in our Google classrooms
and learn coding.
So it would have been nice to
have had that embedded right
into the exhibition so people
would have had the proximity
to what's here and now.
But yeah, I could go on forever.
Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: So Louise, thank
you so, so much for coming.
LOUISE MIRRER: Thank you.
And thank you again.
MALE SPEAKER: And go, go, go,
go to the New York Historical
Society.
And pay full admission please.